هذا احد التحديات التي تقف بوجه روسيا اما
في المقابل في معسكر الغرب لم تحصل
اوكرانيا بعد على اكثر من نصف المساعدات
التي وعدت بها الدول الغربيه بحسب تحليل
صحيفه
ديسمبر الماضي حصلت وزاره الماليه
الاوكرانيه على حوالي 32 مليار دولار من
اصل 77 مليارا وعدت بها الدول الغربيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالشراكه مع بنك
الاستثمار الاوروبي تعهد بتقديم 32 مليار
دولار لم يصل منها الى كييف سوى 19 مليار
دولار لكن الاتحاد ادخل اصلاحات على
اجراءات الدفع في نوفمبر الماضي واعدا
بمساعده ماليه منتظمه بمعدل مليار و600
مليون دولار شهريا بشكل عام وعند احتساب
حجم المساعدات العسكريه والانسانيه يتخلف
الاتحاد الاوروبي عن الولايات المتحده
التي تصدرت تزويد اوكرانيا باكبر قدر من
الذخيره والاسلحه الثقيله
[موسيقى]